AS WE JUST TO OUR NEXT GAME,
TERRIBLE TINDER BIOS.
LAST WEEK ELLE.COM TURNED US
ON TO THE 20 HOTTEST DUDES ON
TINDER AND WE WERE TAKEN BY THE
PROFILE OF THIS GENTLEMAN NAMED
CRILLE, HIS BIO READS I AM WHAT
I AM AND THAT IS ALL I AM AND
I AM IT.
(BLEEP)ING TERRIBLE.
CRILLE LOOKS LIKE HE WAS CREATED
WHEN SOMEONE SPILLED A CRAFT
BEER ON AN EDISON LIGHTBULB
WHILE MUMFORD AND SONS WERE
PLAYING CREED COVER SONGS AT THE
HARD ROCK CASINO.
HE IS LIKE, HE IS LIKE A
TURDICKEN, I THINK IS A--
SADLY WHEN YOU LOOK LIKE HIPSTER
ED HARDY YOUR BIO IS IRRELEVANT.
YOU'RE STILL GOING TO GET LAID.
HOWEVER THE NON-CRILLES OF THE
WORLD CAN MAKE THEMSELVES
"UNDATEABLE" WITH A FEW WRONG
WORDS -- SEE "UNDATEABLE", YOU
SEE HOW IT WORKS.
SO COMEDIANS, I WOULD LIKE YOU
TO COME UP WITH AS MANY TERRIBLE
TINDER BIOS AS YOU CAN IN 60
SECONDS. AND BEGIN!
RON.
>> JUST YOUR AVERAGE CHILL MALE
RIGHT ACTIVIST.
>> Chris: POINTS.
BIANCA.
>> I MAKE GREAT ROOFIE-COLADAS.
>> Chris: POINTS.
RON.
>> DOWN TO JUST HPV NOW.
>> Chris: POINTS.
RICK.
>> MY DICK MAY BE SMALL, BUT AT
LEAST I AM POOR.
>> Chris: POINTS.
BIANCA.
>> I PLAY BURSKI ON
"UNDATEABLE".
>> Chris: POINTS.
RON.
>> MY MOM SAID SHE SWIPED
RIGHT.
>> Chris: POINTS.
RICK.
>> WAIT, THIS ISN'T GRINDR?
>> Chris: POINTS.
RON.
>> THE ONLY GHOSTBUSTERS ARE
MALE GHOSTBUSTERS.
>> Chris: OH, YOU SON OF A
BITCH.
POINTS.
RICK.
>> I HAVE THREE BETA BLACK
LOTUSES AND A SEALED MAGIC
GATHERING STARTER DECK.
>> Chris: POINTS.
BIANCA.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF YOU CAN TELL
BUT THIS IS AUTHENTIC AFFLICTION
ON MY PROFILE.
>> Chris: POINTS. RON.
>> AIN'T NO FUN IF THE HOMIES
CAN'T HAVE NONE.
>> Chris: POINTS.
RON FUNCHES.
BIANCA.
>> I HOPE YOU LIKE FORESKIN.
>> Chris:POINTS.
>> YEAH!